[Music]
in Houston flight director Krantz is
trying to make sense of the barrage of
information completely surrounded with
reports coming in that I don't fully
understand but frankly problems are our
business and I thought we're going to
solve this problem and get back on track
no big deal
where you don't believe that o2 tank one
pressure day no no I honed in on knee
comes I'll ever got principally because
he has the responsibility for those
things you need to stay alive in space
power oxygen pressure heat water let's
get our education to wind up do you guys
okay now do we have instrumentation I'm
realizing that I am the focal point of
all this nothing to brag about can we
tell them anything do we have a real
problem or is it instruments while
Houston struggles to make sense of the
data stream Lovell checks the ships tank
gauges he's in for a shock they wanted a
gauge on one of our oxygen tanks red
zero and I could actually see the deal
go down on the second floor engage very
slowly since oxygen is used both for
breathing and as a source of power it's
vital they find the cause of the
hemorrhage I knew we had an attack
spacecraft obviously I was still
breathing there was no gaping hole that
was letting air out with no sign of a
meteor impact they must search elsewhere
Lovell takes a look outside his window
and I can't tell you the day why I did
it but I saw escaping at a high rate of
speed from the rear end of my spacecraft
a gaseous substance did not take much
intelligence on my part to realize that
the gas escaping and the needle on my
second and last tank were one of the
same and very shortly we'd be completely
out of oxygen
the cold chill of realization came in
that we had a real problem and I don't
know what to do about it
Krantz realizes that 56 hours into their
mission Apollo 13 is poised on the brink
of catastrophe then I move into survival
mode
okay I'll flight controller settle down
quit your guessing let's start working
this problem hey you got two good AC
buses what did all that tell you no but
Lee Bhagat still has no clue what's
happening or how to fix it well just
give me about two more minutes
okay thank you I had to find out where
the leak was and try to isolate it and
try to save the right the remaining part
of the oxygen otherwise the crews gonna
be dead Lee Bhagat realizes his only
hope of isolating the leak is to close
valves that feed oxygen into two of the
fuel cells but closing these valves is
irreversible
those two fuel cells will not work again
[Music]
his final option it is my final option
it's a gamble but it's their only chance
[Music]